alert alert apparently Tom Holland is
seeing someone that isn't zendaya this
is heart date in general you know while
rumors have swirled for a while that the
Spider Man far from home stars are an
item
they have both shot down the gossip why
was it important to Billy hey guys come
on it's like my best friend of course
you know we expected it I mean it comes
with the territory further proof Tom was
spotted laughing being touchy-feely and
holding hands with a mystery woman while
at the Black Eyed Peas concert in
London's Hyde Park on Monday the two
rocked matching black t-shirts and black
pants while they waited to get drinks
and appeared to be way closer than just
friends just look at her hand on his
butt and while Tom and zendaya may not
be a couple they are still totally cute
friends when et caught up with the
co-stars in June to talk about their
Marple flick the former Disney star
called out the 23 year old the way only
besties can with all of you how much you
did in this film we got
behind-the-scenes footage of you and I
mean you're running and pull swinging
and jumping and all the stunts but then
you're getting kind of your butt kicked
the water coming to you slamming into
doors I mean what is that like and you
went into it like okay I'm gonna do this
absolutely I mean when you get given an
opportunity like this you'd be a bit of
an idiot if you didn't go for it you
know and for me when it comes to doing
the stunts I've always been quite an
athletic person and I've always loved
gymnastics so quite an athletic person
and this mystery blonde isn't the only
one with the hots for Tom it's just so
nice to be able to put a smile on their
face Jake admit it on daytime TV that he
thought is sexiest event
I've seen that of all time was you and
we correct and for we came to the
conclusion that the reason he said Chris
Hemsworth was a sympathy vote which
obviously Chris Hemsworth's incredibly
ugly shown so he's just trying to make
Chris feel a bit better about himself
why he said that I would love you to
vote well I would sexiest Avenger I'm
not gonna
[Music]